-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
The Manhattan grand jury
investigating
former President Trump's
alleged involvement
in a hush money payment
is reportedly not expected
to hear any more evidence
for the next month.
Oh, you mean they need
some time off
after hearing nothing
but Trump sex stories?
[ Laughter ]
"Please, we just we just --
we just need a month!"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
several top Republican donors
are worried that Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis
does not have the charisma
for a national campaign.
This guy? This guy
doesn't have the charisma
for a local ad campaign.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like a used car dealer
who insists on being
in the commercials.
[ As DeSantis ]
Come on down to Ron's motors.
Our prices aren't woke
and that's no joke!
[ Laughter ]
Republican Congressman
Mike Gallagher warned this week
that China wants to use
artificial intelligence
to perfect its
"Orwellian surveillance state."
Unfortunately, Republicans
don't know what that means
because they banned that book.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci has reportedly
sold his memoir
for just under $5 million.
He will not narrate
the audiobook, though,
because he knows no one
ever listens to him.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
Two fishermen
who allegedly cheated
in a competitive
fishing competition in Ohio
pleaded guilty this week
to criminal charges
and face up to one year
in prison.
And do you know what they do
to people
who cheat at fishing, in prison?
Because I don't.
[ Laughter ]
I'm guessing it's literally
never happened before.
[ Laughter ]
A travel company has announced
it will offer
the world's longest bus journey
this summer,
which will take riders
on a 56-day trip across Europe
or, for a cheaper 56-day trip,
book a Greyhound
to Jacksonville.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like one of our writers,
Bryan, did that once
and thought maybe
the whole audience had as well.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced yesterday
that the sequel
to author John Grisham's book
"The Firm"
will be released later
this year.
This news first reported
in an all-caps text
from your dad.
[ Laughter ]
Today was baseball's
Opening Day,
with all 30 MLB teams
playing games,
and it's about 40° here
in New York,
so, if you're the Mets,
this is what it feels like
to play in October.
[ Laughter and awws ]
And, finally, the department
store chain Macy's
announced yesterday that its CEO
will retire next year,
while T.J.Maxx announced
their CEO
is just a loose pile of pants.
[ Laughter ]
-And that --
that was a monologue, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We're off and running.